- Did you ever do a mistake at work?
Surely, I did lots of mistakes
during the course of my career.
Many of them when I was young
in the first years after graduating.
But for sure, even today as well.
And I would argue that there's
hardly any senior manager
in any business role
that you could talk to,
who would not have happened
at least one or two
or three major incidents, major mistakes,
major problems that they were more or less
directly responsible for.
Mistakes at work are therefore
nothing to be ashamed of.
The question is rather
how do you deal with them
if they happen and how do you
avoid them for happening again
in the future?
So this is exactly the topic
I'm going to talk about today.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I'm going to address this
topic in three steps.
First, I'm going to share
some typical mistakes
that might often happen to some juniors,
people in the first years of their career.
Second, I'm going to
share some strategies,
what you can do if a
mistake happened to you.
And third, let me share
some tips and tricks
on what you can do to
actually avoid mistakes
in the first place.
So make sure you watch until the end
to see these strategies,
which I find really quite helpful
for your daily life as well.
One of the tips I will talk
about is using checklists
for repeated tasks that you
will need to do frequently.
And here, actually I have a
checklist that I used myself
while I worked at
McKinsey prepared for you.
So you can find it via a link
in the video description,
check it out.
So let's start talking about
what some mistakes could be
that might happen to
you in your daily job.
And frankly, these are all
things that happened to myself.
So I did these mistakes in the past
and surely there are
many, many other things
that you might do wrong at
some point in your career.
So first example: You are
asked to bring handouts
of a document to the meeting,
but you actually forgot to
print out the documents in time.
Now you're sitting in the
meeting without handouts,
everybody's looking at you
and you need to admit that
you did not bring them.
Next, you created an Excel
analysis with some client data,
with some information that you received,
and then you shared some
results from that analysis
with the client or with colleagues.
And then at some point you
find out that some formulas
in the model were wrong, that
your model had a problem.
And likely, the data that
you shared is now inaccurate,
potentially even significantly inaccurate.
The truth is, this likely happens
more often than you think.
I remember a partner
saying that she believes
that likely there is not a
single complex Excel model
that is completely error-free.
So if something like this happens to you,
trust that you will not be the only one.
Or maybe you are asked
a question in a meeting
and then you share the wrong information
because you misremembered it.
So here, one example:
I remember that in one past project,
I was once asked for the savings potential
that we calculated for a specific measure
that we were working on.
And I believe I said something like, yeah,
the savings potential is 20 million Euro,
but in the end it came out
that it was only 5 million
because I just mixed it up
with something else that we calculated.
But in the meantime,
this number was already communicated.
This person has said this to,
communicated this further to other people
in the organization.
So surely this was quite
an unpleasant situation
when then it came out
that this number was not actually correct.
Along these lines, of course,
many other things can go wrong as well.
Maybe you missed the
deadline for a piece of work
that you needed to submit,
or you actually have some
spelling or grammar mistakes
in any of your documents.
All of these are just different examples
of mistakes that could happen to you.
And let me share one more
anecdote of what once happened
in a consulting project.
So we had a big workshop
and an associate was responsible
for preparing this workshop.
And the workshop was a lot
about product line strategy,
lots of numbers prepared for that.
There were board level members
attending this workshop.
We as a consulting firm
had also partners flying in
for the meeting, attending it,
because it just was so
important to the project
that we were conducting.
It was quite a complex session.
There were numbers printed out
on the wall on big wallpapers.
Then we were supposed to
discuss with the clients,
and after starting this discussion,
about 20 minutes into the
workshop it became clear
that all the numbers that were prepared,
that were presented,
were actually wrong.
So apparently that
associate pulled numbers
from a wrong financial year
or something like that.
And unfortunately,
no one noticed until then at some point,
one of the clients noticed that.
And surely this was extremely unfortunate
and surely also extremely
embarrassing for us
as consultants preparing the session.
So having said that,
what should you do if
actually a mistake like this
happens to you?
And one thing that really annoys me
from the perspective of a manager
is when I have the
perception that the person
who did a mistake does
not really acknowledge it,
does not really understand
that the person made a mistake.
Doesn't really seem to care
that that person did something wrong.
So while it is not necessary
to apologize for your mistakes,
so also would not recommend that you say,
"Sorry, sorry, sorry that I did that."
You should at least acknowledge that, yes,
you did something wrong.
That, yes, you understand
that these things should not happen.
That, yes, you will work on
this not happening again.
Because if you don't do or say anything
after you did a mistake,
your team might get the perception
that you don't really care.
Or that for you it's not even important
that your documents are without spelling
or grammar mistakes.
That these things do not
really matter to you.
And this is surely a perception
that you in general want to avoid.
What's important is where it goes
to always keep things in perspective.
So surely a spelling mistake
or not bringing your
handouts to the meeting,
while it's not great,
it's not the end of the world.
So I sometimes see
especially junior people
really beating themselves
up over really minor things.
While, of course, these
things are not great,
they likely have happened
to everyone at some point
in their career.
And surely this is nothing to be scared
or to not sleep well at
night or anything like that.
But sometimes, of course,
also more severe, more
significant things go wrong,
like in the example with a client workshop
that I talked about.
Surely the associate who
prepared the workshop
will not feel great about this,
and probably should really
reflect and introspect
on what happened, what
led to the situation,
why this mistake was done.
When in situations like this,
it's also a question of good leadership,
to not only see the
mistake at the associate
or at the junior colleague
or at the person that
actually prepared the things
in the very end.
Because in the workshop
example it was definitely
also the failure of the project lead
to not double-check the numbers,
to conduct some quality checks
on the works of the associates.
And it surely was also the
responsibility of the partner
to not really work with the
team, challenge the team,
to make sure in the preparatory call
that definitely happened,
make sure that everything is correct
and the documents are in order.
Especially in more complex
situations that go wrong,
while it might sometimes be
easy to just point to one person
who did something wrong,
it is often rather the
failure of the whole team.
Different failures in how
different levels of the team
should collaborate and
should quality check the work
that then in total led to these issues.
What's always important
if you do a mistake
is to actually be open
and honest about it.
And here, again, let me
share one anecdote from work.
There was once a situation
where a project lead was sitting together
with a board member,
and then also one or two
other partners around.
And then the board member asked the team,
asked the project lead
whether he already reached out
to another client,
a colleague of the board member,
to circulate and talk about
the results with that person.
And in that situation,
the project lead said,
yes, he did that, right?
He talked to that person,
he circulated this information
already with the person.
But for whatever reason,
the board member was a
bit skeptical about that.
So in the meeting,
the board member called this client
and asked the person
whether such an interaction,
such a meeting actually took place.
And it came out that this did not happen,
so that frankly,
the project lead lied to the board member.
And probably the project
lead did not even intend
anything bad.
Likely he just wanted to cover up,
that probably he did not do this,
which likely he should should have done.
Probably he would have directly
after the meeting reach out
to this other person and
then share the numbers,
share the data to get this in order.
So while at that moment,
to the project lead
this likely just seemed
to be a little minor cover up,
the damage that then
resulted from the situation
was of course significant.
The trust between the board
member and the consulting team
was directly gone.
And certainly the project lead also faced
internal consequences after this incident.
So while sometimes you might
get away with something,
I would really recommend you
to make it a habit of yours
of always saying the truth, be honest,
be open about what happened.
Don't try dodgy things,
covering things up,
because it will come
to situations like this
where things can really, really hurt you,
hurt your career,
hurt, of course, the
reputation of your firm,
of your employer,
and this is usually not
worth it in the end.
Now let me share one maybe
a little bit sneaky hack
that I once learned from a project lead
whenever you did something wrong.
And from this project lead
I learned the principle
that you should share good
news always in writing,
but bad news only verbally, right?
So good news in writing,
bad news when you did
something wrong, only verbally.
And the reason for that is that
if you did something great,
you can write about this.
Then maybe your team lead,
other members of your team
receive this as an email,
for instance.
They can potentially forward it around,
forward it to to other
people in the organization.
So more people learn about what you did,
about the great things that happen.
Surely this is what you want.
Though the other way around
this is what you might avoid
when you actually did something wrong,
when you did a mistake,
when you did an error.
So yes, be open and honest about it.
Maybe give a call to your team lead
to disclose what happened,
to think about what
the next steps could be
to rectify the situation.
But try to do this verbally,
in person or on the phone,
but do not put this
information in an email,
because, again, if it
is written in an email,
then that person might forward
it to other team members.
Then more and more colleagues
might learn about that,
or maybe half a year later,
that person is going
over his or her inbox.
And then suddenly this
email pops up again.
And they remember the situation,
they remember this mistake,
this error that you did at the time,
which they might already have forgotten
if you just shared it with them verbally.
So share good news in writing
and bad news only verbally.
So I agree that this might
be a little bit sneaky,
but this still appears
to be fair game to me
and just a little hack that
you can use in your daily work.
Next I will share some
strategies that you can apply
to actually avoid some of the mistakes
that we just talked about.
But before that,
I would like to introduce you
to the sponsor of this
week's video, DXC Luxoft.
Luxoft is a global digital strategy
and software engineering firm
that delivers IT and
business consulting services
to their clients.
Luxsoft, at the moment,
has a lots of open roles
to fill, both in Germany,
but also all their other
offices around the world.
So if you are interested in
new job opportunities in IT
or in consulting,
I will leave links to their German
and their international career page below
in the video description.
Luxsoft focuses on the public sector.
So they help the public administration
to become more digital and
improve their processes.
At Luxsoft you will have the
opportunity to work together
with federal governments,
states, major cities,
and help them improve.
To me this sounds like quite
an exciting opportunity.
Also with the potential to
really create a positive impact
for the public domain.
They're looking for people at
different experience levels
with a passion for IT that want to grow
into a more managerial,
business-minded role.
They also have open
roles in SAP consulting
and the SAP S/4HANA platform.
So if any of this sounds
interesting to you,
check out the links
to their career page's
individual description.
Of course, the best way
to deal with mistakes is
to avoid them in the first place.
So now let me share a couple
of tips and strategies
that you can use to avoid
or at least decrease the
numbers of mistakes that you do.
The first is to work with checklists.
So whenever you do a task repeatedly
and this task is prone to errors,
use a checklist with all the things
that you want to regularly check
before you hand in the deliverable.
In professional services
jobs, like consulting,
one thing where this for sure
will be helpful are documents.
In the beginning of my career
I often did minor mistakes
in my documents
and for that I created a checklist
that I always went through,
that I always checked
before I actually sent
and distributed a document
to colleagues or to clients.
So if you're interested in
this checklist that I used,
you can actually download it.
I will include a download link
below in the video description.
So I polished it a little bit,
but at its core,
it's really the checklist that I used
while I worked at McKinsey.
So I hope several of you
will find it helpful as well.
Feel free to download
it for free, of course,
via the link in the video description.
Another tactic that you could
and should use are check sums
and plausibility checks
in your Excel models.
So as a consultant,
you will very frequently work with models.
Often, also write complex
and large financial models.
Here it's very important
to include maybe one tab
with different check sums,
different plausibility checks
where you do calculations like,
oh, probably the sum of all
these figures should equal
this other figure that you
have there in the other tab.
You'll do different checks
like that, plausibility checks,
because, of course,
you will over time frequently
change assumptions,
change data inputs in such a model.
And sometimes these changes can lead
to certain elements of the model breaking,
which you should be able to detect
with techniques like this.
Next tip is to print out documents.
So surely you here, maybe
people are different,
but I can definitely say, for myself,
and I know that this is true
for many other colleagues as well,
that for me it is always
much easier to spot mistakes
in documents,
so let it be grammar or spelling mistakes,
but also content mistakes,
things that just do not align,
do not really fit,
if I have the document printed out,
compared to just looking
at it on a screen,
maybe even a small screen
on a small notebook.
So whenever possible, especially
for important documents,
I would recommend you to print them out,
have them there in front of you,
go over it page by page and
check every single thing.
Read everything,
just to make sure the document is fine.
And by this, you will likely
spot all the last mistakes.
And last but not least,
one technique that is
really highly effective
if you work in a team and you
jointly worked on a document,
is to, before you send it out,
you sit all together in your team room,
you project the document to the wall,
and then the whole team
looks at every single slide,
every single page for a couple of seconds
and try to spot any errors,
any inconsistencies.
And then you really go slide by slide
and jointly have a look at it together
to discuss this and to criticize this.
So this, from my experience,
is really a highly effective measure.
Of course, you could
just send it to everyone,
and tell everyone, "Oh,
please read it yourself.
Spot the mistakes."
But then, like, not everyone
will do this very diligently.
If you have everyone together
and just 100% focused
on reviewing the document,
here the chances are quite
high that you will really find
even the most minor
problems on the slides.
So of course there will
be many other techniques
that you could apply as well.
Here I'd love to have some tips from you.
What are some strategies
that you can share
on how to avoid errors
and mistakes in your work?
Feel free to leave them
below in the comment section.
Just leave a comment and I
trust that will be helpful
to everyone else reading
the comment section as well.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe and
turn on notifications
to always be informed whenever
I release a new video.
And, of course, also big
thanks again to the sponsor
of this week's video, Luxsoft.
Check out their career opportunities
in the link in the video description.
Again, if you're interested
in that checklist,
the document checklist,
there's a link in the video
description to that as well.
And last but not least,
I also wanna say a big thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Thanks for your support. This
is very much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So good weekend to all of
you. See you again next week.
Very much looking forward
to that. So have a good day.